aujourd'hui est un jour qui est attendu
depuis un petit moment parce que mois de
plus a officialisé deux nouveaux
smartphones one + 8 one plus une pro on
a ici les deux boîtes alors voyez pas
forcément la différence pour voir la
différence il faut se mettre sur le côté
one + 8 fois de plus fait pour
aujourd'hui je sors deux vidéos en même
temps de vidéo test pour vous présenter
et vous donner mon retour sur ces deux
smartphones
dans cette vidéo présente sur le web + 8
le web plus fluide pour selon une autre
vidéo d'ailleurs le lien est dans la
description vous allez maria vraiment
grosse grosse différence entre ces deux
produits le web plus fluide c'est plus
le smartphone peut-être pour tout le
monde
tandis que dwan que je suis pro sesto
one plus fait de mieux une énorme fiche
technique c'est des [ __ ] complète
c'est de la démesure totale et ça je
vous en parle dans notre vidéo vous
inviterez donc allé là bois puisque les
deux vidéos sont complémentaires
la première chose que je vous montre
très très rapidement ses salles à ça on
a la chance en tant que média d'avoir
une boîte complète et que je trouve très
sympa ça vous bougez votre miller sitl
ça c'est vachement sympa alors ça on en
parle dans la vidéo du web plus fluide
trop petite surprise vous allez voir
c'est vachement intéressante mais pour
l'heure on va concentrer là dessus sur
le wan +8 première chose la boîte
toujours sympa bien travaillé le huis
clos qui ressort mais plus besoin de
marquer la marque la marque on la
retrouve sur les côtés on a ici un de
plus et on est ici le modèle one + 8
pareil quand on est d'ouvrir entre le 8
sur le côté ici le smartphone mais j'ai
déjà enlevé on a une petite languette
qui nous permettent de venir retirer la
partie là on se retrouve avec une petite
coque transparente si vous voulez venir
protéger l'europe allemand quelques
temps à venir protéger votre smartphone
parce que ça c'est extrêmement important
votre bloc de charge et 6 30 watts on en
parle dans la partie autonomie un tout
petit peu plus loin et comme d'habitude
vous avez votre câble rouge avec une
connectique usb c'est et l'usb l'autre
côté côté design on parlera de tout
l'inconnu on les sent quelque chose
qu'on connaît déjà on va retrouver les
codes domaine place ici on a un triple
module photo et je vous le dirai dans
quelques instants on va retrouver le
branding ou une place ici sur le côté
ici on a un petit bouton pour via
l'allumé pour éteindre est ici pour
venir switch est votre mode sonnerie
vibreur silencieux un grand classique
sur une place en dessous un haut parleur
de l'usbc et si votre tiroir de double
d'un aussi mme petit micro de côté le
bouton de volume et sur le dessus le
micro pour la réduction brute c'est un
smartphone qui se tient bien en main
mais qui assez glissant il faut donc
venir le protéger rien de tel que de
bonnes coque de protection et des
protections d'écran au civil
en partenariat avec rhinochill j'ai donc
de quoi faire alors j'ai pas les
nouvelles coques pour le one + 8 me pour
le pôle sud projet par contre les coptes
des anciens modèles vous allez pouvoir
vous commandez les nouvelles coques nous
a mis un lien en bas de la description
qu'ils signaient des coqs mais pas que
puisque vous avez des protections
d'écran vous avez les protections aussi
au niveau du dos qu'au bien-être sur vos
smartphones vous avez bien évidemment
les souliers de suite qu'ils sont les
coques de rhinau chine et si vous
préférez vous avez également les crashs
garde comme ça vous protégez votre
smartphone de tous les côtés et vous
pouvez garder le dos visible on a ici un
écran bord à bord incurvé de face mais
également dodu corning gorilla glass 5 à
l'arrière mais également à l'avant et
surtout la grosse nouveauté au lieu
d'avoir une petite goutte ici vous
retrouvez une caméra qui est planqué
dans un poinçon un smartphone qui est
pas extrêmement lourds qui fait 180
grammes et on a ici un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est
extrêmement réactif et qui dit les
routes très très rapidement 128 suite le
design j'ai pas grand chose à dire si il
est efficace il marche bien on reste
dans ce que faisait one plus on voit
qu'un petit déplacement et vous la
caméra de saïfi le poinçon et mieux
intégré que la goutte la prise en main
est bonne donc sur toute la partie
design pour moi ça me va bien
le modèle que j'ai eu six mois c'est le
onyx blacks on voit quelques marques
quelques traces de doigts je vous
conseille quand même devenir le protéger
pour éviter de lauriers mais on pourra
retrouver également en glacis green qui
est un bleu qui tire sur le verre et qui
lui par contre un effet mat
ici on a un écran de 6 5 pouces de
diagonale c'est un écran flux d'un maul
est fabriqué par samsung
la résolution c'est du full hd plus de
1400 par mille 800 pixels à 400 de
pixels par pouce on un ratio vingt
neuvième donc assez allongée et surtout
un écran qui occupent 92,16 % de la
façade ont une dalle samsung qui est
très bien maîtrisée qui est calibrée en
vif et moi je vous conseille de rester
en vie vous pouvez à la nature elle ça
va le devenir légèrement ça va adoucir
un petit peu moi j'aime bien le côté vif
après vous pouvez aller dans avancé et
là vous avez le choix soit vous restez
dans la gamme de couleurs amoled soit
vous pouvez avoir du sgb ou alors du
display p3 on a ici un écran avec un
taux de rafraîchissement 90 ans vous
pouvez aussi choisir 60r si vous le
souhaitez vous allez économiser un peu
plus la batterie par défaut il faut vous
restiez en 90 90 heures ça va consommer
davantage mais par contre une sélection
intelligente donc en fonction de
l'application dans laquelle vous allez
vous situer votre smartphone d'un module
est automatiquement entre 90 hertz ou 60
hertz et si vous n'aimez pas le petit
point sont apparents et s'ils pouvaient
venir le masquer mais joli tout de suite
c'est vraiment pas pour gagner c'est à
dire vous réduire tout ça ça vous
augmente la bordure en eau donc bien que
ce ne soit pas complètement parfait
devant les petites caméras sur la face
avant
malgré tout c'est quand même mieux ici
on a une dalle hd m
agir 10 plus nous apportera plus de
couleurs et un meilleur contraste on est
en plus un écran 10 bits alors un écran
dit ça vous apporte quoi ça vous apporte
un milliard de couleurs ce qui fait vous
allez avoir meilleure gestion de la
colorimétrie sur votre écran que ce soit
pour venir jouer à des jeux pour
regarder des films des photos ce que
vous voulez les couleurs sont beaucoup
plus belle en écran qui certifiait
lutter contre la lumière bleue qui est
luminosité maximale de 1110 alors moi ce
que je peux vous dire là dessus c'est
que je trouve qu'effectivement il est
très lumineux je suis à l'extérieur il
fait très beau on voit très bien il ya
une très bonne lisibilité
le fait d'avoir un écran 90 heures ça
vous apporte de la fluidité est ce que
vous allez dire scrollé surtout pour les
personnes qui veulent jouer à des jeux
alors lé top mais elle n'est pas aussi
top que ce qu'on a avec le modèle pro
mais ça c'est une autre histoire je vous
en parle dans la vidéo dédiée au moins
de plus huit pros la partie multimédia
est très très très bonne avec des
haut-parleurs stéréo j'avais à haut
parleurs là et vous utilisez tous
parlant vous avez là ça a pas vraiment
de la spatialisation pu vous regardiez
un fils d'écouter de la musique joue à
des jeux ça c'est vraiment bien on a ici
un son dolby et moss vous pouvez laisser
en dynamique par défaut pour le laisser
choisir intelligemment film qui va venir
ouvrir et spécialiser davantage et vous
avez également un préréglage musique
personnellement j'ai apprécié aussi
écouter de la musique avec le réglage
film qui est aussi vraiment adapté et si
vous voulez utiliser un casque sans fil
vous pouvez le faire puisque vous avez
étudié bluetooth 5 points en plus de ça
vous avez les codecs à ptx à péter x hdl
d à c est assez donc en termes
d'expérience musicale vous avez vraiment
de quoi faire personnellement j'étais
vraiment satisfait par la partie
multimédia que soit l'écran qui est
vraiment tabou soit la partie audio qui
est très bien spécialisés
quand tes performances moins deux blocs
s'est fait plaisir en proposant ce
l'effet de mieux un snapdragon 865 de la
ram lp ddr5 et du stockage en ufr 3.0 on
a ici les dernières technologies
meilleures technologies dragon 865 c'est
à ce jour le meilleur processeur de
smartphone le plus rapide la ram respect
ddr5 apporter plus de fluidité et le
stockage en fs 3.0 vous apportera une
meilleure lecture écriture donc vous
avez une expérience complètement
maximisée
en plus derrière d'un point de vue
logiciel oxygen games propose de la ram
boost pour complètement venir optimiser
votre smartphone pour la party gaming
mais pas que côté performances sonores
smartphones qui atteint le score de 574
1746 surtout tous et qui vient vous le
classer numéro un numéro 1 par rapport à
ce qu'elle enregistrait aujourd'hui j'ai
trouvé que le chien au mileu milices pro
obtenez un meilleur score
mais tout ça est bien évidemment ça se
tient dans un mouchoir de poche mais ça
ne s'arrête pas là puisque ici vous avez
un smartphone 5 g vous allez donc
pouvoir vous connecter à la 5g dès lors
que la 5g sera éligible
là où vous habitez ou alors lorsque vous
déplacer à l'étranger peu importe de la
5g oui mais pas que vous pouvez
également avoir du wi fi ce 6 pour la
noce maroc permettra de vous connecter
partout facilement avec ce qui se fait
de mieux en termes de connectivité en
termes de technologie l'autonomie c'est
toujours un point qui est extrêmement
intéressant qui dépend bien évidemment
toujours de vous ici vous avez une
batterie de 4300 milliampères heures si
vous l'utilisez intensivement voudrez
bien évidemment la journée si vous y
allez avec un peu plus de souplesse
un jour et demi et si vous êtes
carrément tranquille deux jours mais
surtout le point très positif c'est que
vous avez de l'avare charge 30 et vous
permettra de recharger de 0 à 50 % en
seulement 23 minutes
ici on tombe sur oxygen os qui est une
des meilleure surcouche disponible
aujourd'hui sur le marché
oxygène os 10 qui tourne sur android 10
vous avez beaucoup de possibilités et
notamment en termes de personnalisation
vous pouvez choisir mais évidemment
terme prédéfinis lumière d'élimination
ou alors carrément intel sombre vous
avez différents packs d'icône vous
pouvez choisir la forme de vos icônes la
couleur d'accentuation la tonalité bien
évidemment les polices les fonds d'écran
aux reason light sur le côté
l'animation de l'empreinte digitale
l'horloge et vous avez beaucoup
d'options dans votre menu on a ici un
smartphone qui un triple module photo
tout en haut vous allez avoir un ultra
grand angle d'un 16 mégapixels qui ouvre
à f 2.2 et qui est un champ de vision de
116 degrés juste en dessous c'est la
caméra principale celle à 48 mégapixels
ce une sony mx 5 186 kg ouvre à f 1.75
stabilisation optique puces
électroniques les une taille de pixel
qui fait 0.8 micro et qui vous permettra
d'avoir un zoom numérique x 2 et de
sortir des photos de 12 mégapixels car
sa technologie ka pixels en est toute en
dessous vous avez une caméra macro de 2
mégapixels qui n'a absolument aucune
stabilisation qui ouvre à f 2.4 un
double flash led qui planquaient juste
en dessous tandis qu'à l'avant vous avez
une caméra de cette fille de 16
mégapixels c'est la sony mx 471 quand
une stylisation électronique qui ouvre à
f 2.0 point de vue logiciel ça marche
parfaitement bien c'est
-visite très simple vous voyez qui si
vous êtes en mode 12 mégapixels vous
cliquez paf vous passer carrément 48
mégapixels
si vous voulez la macro vous appuyer
directement ici et si vous voulez passer
son ultra grand-angle il vous suffit
d'appuyer ici et vous avez un petit
bouton qui s'est rajouté c'est le bouton
paramètres vous venez de cliquer là et
vous avez accès à toutes vos options sur
la partie vidéo ou à des options qui
sont assez intéressantes pouvait filer
bien évidemment en 1080p à 30 à 60
images par seconde en 4k à 30 à 60
images par seconde mais également de la
4k signer 30 ou 60 images par seconde au
format 21 9ème sais pas si ça vous parle
de format 21/9 c'est un format qui est
extrêmement allongé c'est le format
cinémascope c'est le format du cinéma
donc si vous avez envie de venir faire
de la création avec vos smartphones et
bien vous pouvez le faire en 4k plus ce
soit au format 21 9ème ou pas vous avez
du super slow motion 480 images par
seconde en 720p du 240 images par
seconde en 1080p
pourquoi pas sûr qu'on utilise beaucoup
du timelapse en 4k à 30 images par
seconde mais également en 1080p à 30
images par seconde et vous avez une
super stabilisation 1080p ou 4k à 30
images par seconde un point qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que vous avez
une reconnaissance des animaux donc si
vous avez un chien et un chat que
voulait venir prendre une photo vous
avoir des photos qui vont être optimisé
malheureusement je n'ai pas tiens je
n'ai pas de chahoumian confinement je ne
peux donc pas dire tester mais en tout
cas s'ils le disent c'est celle à
fonctionner donc c'est plutôt bien d'un
point de vue purement et simplement
configuration ce que vous avancez votre
48 mais la fixait la saône mx 5 186
quelque chose qu'on connaît déjà
c'est un capteur qui fonctionne très
bien qui est maîtrisé on l'a eu dans
beaucoup de smartphones de l'année
dernière donc ici rien de bien neuf plus
ultra grand-angle pareil ça fonctionne
je vous montrais rester en quelques
instants je parle vraiment uniquement
purement du choc et a fait par une
pucelle suis par contre de mettre une
caméra ici macro de 2 mégapixels il y a
plusieurs constructeurs qu'ils font
personnellement je suis pas
particulièrement emballé on va regarder
les résultats dans quelques secondes
pour ma part ben voilà ça c'est pas
terrible un peu pétard mouillé c'est
vraiment un des pauvres se dire on a un
triple module photo ici mais je trouve
que deux ont été largement suffisant
alors est-ce que ça a été un petit peu
en dessous par rapport à ce qu'on peut
retrouver à la concurrence à ce tarif là
mais le 2 méga pixels pour moi voilà
mais je vais vous montrer les résultats
vous allez voir voici les photos du one
+ 8 alors ici on est sans capteur
principal d'un point de vue d'ensemble
on ait le colorimétrie que je trouve
assez juste on voit bien les nuages en
eau dans une bonne gestion de la plage
dynamique on voit bien les tailles sur
les feuilles rien est cramé
les détails dans les zones un peu plus
d'ombré fonctionne aussi donc sur le
capteur principal ça marche parfaitement
bien on passe ainsi sur l'ultra grand
angle le progrès intéressants regardez
là dessus c'est la différence de
colorimétrie entre l'ultra grand temps
les capteurs principal et voyez que
franchement il y en a un tout petit peu
mais c'est extrêmement léger et c'est
très bien maîtrisée de la pardonne plus
je switche entregent et lot prenez un
poids regardez vous voyez c'est très
très proches
et ça fonctionne parfaitement bien on
voit bien tous les détails des nuages
on voit également les feuilles dans les
zones un peu plus ombragé vous avez
travaillé sur la vidéo du one + 8 pro
vous allez voir reconduit comme une
différents mails ultra-grand-angle fait
le boulot en passant film sur le zoom x
2 pouvoir compter sur un zoom numérique
lui rendu assez qualitatif x 5 on
récupère quand même pas mal de bruit
c'est pas terrible et fois dix fois la
ccit voilà c'est vraiment histoire de
rapprocher capteur principal ultra
grand-angle
il ya un très très bel équilibre du
couleurs entre les deux ça s'est
vraiment bien une fois de plus qu'un
décret mais on a bien tous les détails
ici dans les apps on voit bien dans les
zones d'ombré également ici les petites
feuilles on se rapproche
une fois de plus ça fonctionne x 5 il ya
du bruit x 10 il ya beaucoup trop de
bruit capteur principal
ultra-grand-angle différentes saturation
des plus saturés thyssen principal que
sur l'ultra grand-angle capteur
principal ultra-grand-angle on va bien
les nuages si c'est un peu plus pâle que
sur le capteur principal un peu plus
saturés ici on se rapproche en fois de
sava et froide liste voilà qu'en parlant
par capteur principal ultra-grand-angle
hollande si vous verrez vous avez
vraiment finalement la vidéo du but le
plus pro parce que c'est vraiment
intéressant et ses lèvres sur cette
photo ac on va vraiment les différences
de l'ultra content j'ai fait exactement
les mêmes fautes au même endroit pour
pouvoir venir comparez vous verrez que
son ultra grand-angle du web plus une
pro il ya quand même une différence
on se rapproche en x 2 1 x 10 voilà
ainsi complètement inexploitables la
question la banqueroute sûr très
intéressante et sur les capteurs avec
très peu de mégapixels s'est toujours
pas terrible alors ici effectivement on
peut dire qu'à on voit un petit peu les
détails et vous avez du bruit partout
ses patins je suis vraiment pas fan
on a une fleur qui très très bruitée là
c'est pareil regarder le niveau de la
tige vont perdre tous les détails à
cause du bruit alors cette photo là il
est bien parce que vous avez un vrai
contraste entre le blanc entre le violet
et vous verrez une fois de plus haute
est du vrai plus prompt que c'est
vraiment tout autre chose
c'est vraiment le temps de mettre un
capteur pour avoir un capteur mais voilà
je suis vraiment pas compris comme elle
la caméra de celle fille fait un boulot
qui est quand même plutôt bon c'est pas
ce qui arrive du côté du mode portrait
il m'a vraiment sursaturé le flou
d'arrière-plan est pas mal le découpage
est pas mauvais on peut également faire
un mode portrait avec l' ultra
grand-angle le détourage est assez juste
à la colorimétrie est bonne la ici c'est
un peu perdu
sinon dans l'ensemble le résultat est
assez correcte je veux montrer les
photos que j'ai fait en condition de
nuit voir dans quelles conditions on
était j'ai pas mis de l'eau ode dessus
j'ai pas mis de colorimétrie pour vous
voyez c'est vraiment flag de chez flat
et voilà les photos qu'on a obtenu là
avec le capteur principal c'est très
brute et la gestion du mode nuit est
vraiment pas très très bonne là dessus
et sur l' ultra grand-angle voilà il y a
rien à voir pour le coup il fait nuit
chez lui il ya vraiment beaucoup de
bruit est là pour moi le one + 8 et pas
du tout à la hauteur
et pareil sur le fragmentant l'on voit
absolument rien
[Musique]
comme vous lisez vous avez une double
dan aussi mais vous n'avez pas ici de
cas microsd vont peu non pas venir
augmenter le stockage de votre
smartphone vous faites vraiment bien
choix dans les deux conflits qui
existent 128 256 bon déjà comme ça vous
donne vraiment de quoi faire vous avez
du nfc par contre c'est un smartphone
qui n'a pas de certification ip68 il
faut savoir que les one + 8 pro à une
certification ip68 donc ça c'est une
vraie nouveauté par rapport à ce qu'on
avait avant
mais ce modèle là ne l'a pas pourtant il
est conçu quasiment de la même manière
qu'on n'a pas de caméra pop up je suis
donc surpris qu'on n'ait pas
certification de 68 ou mais là ça
devient très intéressant sur la version
us de ce smartphone
vous avez une certification ip68
pourquoi parce que l'opérateur team
obeid exige que ce smartphone est une
certification ip67 pour le mettre à son
catalogue
ça veut donc dire que du point de vue
purement matérielles on a un smartphone
qui est éligible à la certification ip68
puisqu'il est dans un autre pays mais
pour la version qu'on a ici en europe
et bien non vous n'avez pas
certification ip68 pourquoi parce que
certification ip68 ça coûte de l'argent
c'est 20 à 25 $ par device ce qui fait
que ça augmenterait le prix de votre
smartphone
je pense que sur ce smartphone la one +
a vraiment voulu être compétitif
alors justement le tarif puisqu'on en
parle laissez moi prendre la petite
feuille que ces choses que j'apprends
jamais par coeur on a donc deux
configurations 8 +128 giga de stockage
en version noire c'est cette version là
la voyez c'est celui là que j'ai ici
il coûte 699 euros et vous avez une
version 12 plus de 156 qui en glace les
grilles en fer sur matt qui est à 799
euros
un smartphone dispo à partir du 21 mai
prochain dès qu'il sera dispo je vous
mettrai les liens en bas dans la
description
rapprochez-vous noir après chaudement on
reste dans l'intimité là ce qui est
intéressant est ce qu'on voit là dessus
c'est que on a les tarifs qui augmente
quand même on n'est pas sur un
smartphone
en tout 500 euros on n'est pas sur un
smartphone en dessous de 600 euros on
est sur un smartphone un tout petit peu
en tout 700 euros il ya une augmentation
de plus pourquoi parce que votre plus
n'a pas voulu vous les et en termes de
spécifications techniques on a le
meilleur processeur on a un très bon
écran certes on n'a pas senti fication
ip68 mais on a quelque chose qui marche
vraiment bien et surtout ce qu'il a
vraiment augmenté la nôtre celle à 5 g
vous avez un modem 5 g coûte plus cher
pour moi ce smartphone il peut être fait
pour vous si vous voulez une très
une expérience multimédia sa pâle
expérience optimale comme ce que vous
allez avoir selon elle peut suivre
promet ça je vous avais une fois de plus
à bien voir le test du bois de plus huit
pros comme ça vous saurai tout on a un
très bon écran l'aspect multimédia est
vraiment excellent l'aspect performance
est très bon l'autonomie est très bonne
la recharge et rapide la photo est
honnête sur le 48 mégapixels ultra
grand-angle why not mais le reste voyez
voilà ça ça reste un petit peu en
dessous on peut pas tout avoir non plus
si on veut avoir le must est le meilleur
moyen domaine plus il faut aller sur le
site pro ça c'est une autre histoire ça
coûte un peu plus cher quand même mais
je vous dis tout dans le test d'une
bonne plus trop à vous de me gave attend
vos ce que vous en pensez comment vous
trouvez ça aurait de plus suite est ce
que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
est ce que vous aimez est ce que vous
trouvez intéressant ce qu'a proposé
moins de plus là dessus en terme de
fiches techniques
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
augmentation de prix est ce que vous
avez eu un modèle antérieur donne plus
est ce que vous pourriez vous été tenté
par seconde plus vite remarqué ma tout
ça en bas en commentaire et quant à nous
on se retrouve dès demain pour continuer
à parler de teck vous allez voir il ya
quelque chose à raconter et bisous
d'amour à demain
[Musique]